[Music]
today we're tackling a paper that's
basically legendary at least in the
world of natural language processing NLP
for those in the know right attention is
all you need it's not just a catchy
title definitely
[Music]
not o cam a general purpose functional
programming language that is also an
imperative language and also an
objectoriented language it is what
hascal which is could
[Music]
be hey everyone my name is Mam and I'm
excited to talk about the va's first
open-source video editing
agent backstory is that we needed some
automatic tool to edit videos for res
skill. a platform for personalized
learning while doing so we quickly
realized limitations of FFM p and
started looking for more intuitive and
flexible Alternatives remotion was nice
but it did unreliable service side
rendering after trying out core we
really likeed the API as it did not
require the separate rendering backend
we met with the author of the library
and decided to collaborate and build
this agent
together the core library from diffusion
Studio can do complex compositions via
JavaScript typescript based programmatic
interface meaning we can use llm to
generate code to run this
and if we take a step further and let
our llm write its own action in code
it's a perfect match simply because code
is the best possible way to express
actions performed by a
computer lastly multiple research papers
have shown that having llm tool calling
in code is much better than in
Json now let's take a look at current
architecture agent starts a browser
session using
playright and connects to operator UI
this web app is video editing UI
designed specifically for AI agents it
renders video directly in browser using
web codex
API it also has helper
functions for transferring files from
python to browser and back via chromium
Dev tool protocol
this is a typical flow of agent we have
three main tools video editing tool doc
Search tool and visual feedback tool
first a video editing tool generates
code based on user prompt and runs it in
browser if additional context is needed
doc Search tool uses rck to pull the
relevant
information after each execution step a
composition the compositions are sampled
currently at one frame per second and
they they are fed to visual feedback
tool visual feedback tool can be sold as
uh generator and discriminator like in
famous gun
architecture after the visual feedback
tool gives green light the agent
proceeds to render the
composition we also shipped lm. txt
which is essentially robots.txt but for
agents you can see sample in the screen
lm. txt in addition with specific
template prompts will take you far in
your video editing
Journey while while you can bring your
own browser and run the agent the
current setup is also flexible enough to
let the agent connect to a remote
browser session via web soet and each
agent can get the separate browser
session which is GP view accelerated and
of course there's a load balance load
balancer behind
this of course the first version of the
agent is in Python but typescript
implementation is
underway as the F famous saying goes any
applications that can be written in
typescript will be written in
typescript thank you very much this was
collaboration between diffusion studio
and rkill